Question 4 of the popular consultation do you agree that the
Ecuadorian state should recognize international arbitration as a
method to resolve disputes regarding contractual or commercial investment?
To answer this question we must first know what international arbitration is?
International arbitration is an alternative method of conflict
resolution that instead of going to a national court of justice,
they opt for this option.
I give you an example,
the Ecuadorian state signs a contract with an international
company to execute any type of work in the country and it
turns out that either party can or does not comply with the
clauses established in that contract and even have a conflict,
This would be an option to resolve it but
as long as the two parties are in agreement.
Here is the annex to this question so that you can analyze it
where it says that Article 422 of the Constitution should be replaced,
where international arbitration is currently prohibited.
For this new one,
the Ecuadorian state may enter into treaties or
subscribe to international instruments that contemplate
rules for dispute resolution through international arbitration.
This question is very controversial before the eyes and thoughts of
many Ecuadorians but it is because they have their point and it is
valid but I tell you what is the positive and negative part of this question.
On the positive side,
there is a greater possibility of foreign investment than this
translates into jobs in economic development inization of our
economy and also greater legal certainty for foreign investors.
negative It is that this question is misused.